God shook the country of Japan he
literally grabbed the country by the
shoulders and said hey look
I'm here I'm just so overjoyed and so
encouraged I'm not gonna do it
apparently you guys have been telling me
the tsunami girl is a troll uh I
apparently had no idea what a troll was
I I assume that you were talking about
the way she looked that and I assume
that you were telling me that she lived
under a bridge which would explain why
the [ __ ] is crazy
do I believe she's a troll you're not a
troll you know why is because you were
afraid that we were gonna come after you
and whip your ass and you know what
you're right the moment you got those
emails that a whole bunch of Asian
people want to come in whoop your ass
you were like oh yeah I'm a troll gotcha
April fourth [ __ ] what you trying to
pull this March God is such an amazing
God he is so good and so loving and then
you go off and saying that it's a
blessing from God are you kidding me
right now [ __ ] the moment you said
that God was like me no I never met you
before no creep I don't think I created
you I the only reason why you would say
the tsunami is a blessing is because
obviously you never been hit by one I
guarantee it just like being a thug
everybody thinks a thug until they get a
gun in the face how do I know it
happened to me no get off me men who Sun
you and you're cross-eyed mama nobody
talking to you
yeah about that yeah did I say anything
about your mom I don't I don't mind her
at all once he hits Europe once he hits
America it's just gonna be crazy it's
gonna be insane and it's gonna happen to
America and you're a man you just hate
everybody don't you those are your
people
[ __ ] that's all you got do you even
know what a tsunami is cuz I'm starting
to think that you think it's a new
Pokemon game you know what I want like I
hope you get hit by a tsunami
I hope you do and I hope you survive
only to get dragged down them in the
ocean where you get your ass whipped by
a gang of dolphins and how you gonna be
that close to a video camera without
brushing your damn hair looking like you
just got off the Mayflower yet pilgrim
but your fuzzy ass eyebrows looking like
two caterpillars chasing each other
[ __ ] on a side note um I heard that
Alexander Wallis uh left UCLA and [ __ ]
my bad Mexico Ryan is back to Mexico
Mexican city
yeah Mexican that's my foot door at the
very same thing here I thought you a
filipino a lie you fit you work out a
little bit yeah I can tell you feel I
can look like you one day I'm a baby
yeah I just started what why you got
there in today huh today now I like your
accent dude up I'm slightly attracted to
you right now I'm over here trying to
get a personal interview with my with my
best friend mr. gold mr. go
excuse me mr. go yes um see you up
you sell me huh excuse me mr. go hey
come on man all right what hey let's
have a conversation will quick egg
what's going on hey let's go oh okay
well your people contact my people cool
what's up All Right see you later me all
right cool